Helena is standing by for us in Beijing
this morning hi Helena good morning to
you what do we know about this meeting
well we know that it's incredibly
important she will arrive in Moscow
today we understand that they will have
some closed-door meetings dinner
together tonight and then more formal
meetings
um tomorrow but look these these leaders
have met many times before they are
self-confessed friends but the stakes
have never been higher and the reason
for that of course is the context of
that war in Ukraine and crucially what
China's position on that war is now
China has always maintained that it is
neutral in the war that it hasn't taken
either sides that it is a peacemaker
that it's one of the only countries that
could feasibly broker a piece because
it's one of the only countries that
hasn't provided weapons to either side
for example the west of course might
raise eyebrows at that because quietly
behind the scenes China has provided
Russia with financing and technology and
crucial diplomatic cover as well so lots
of questions about what might come out
of this meeting certainly president XI
wants to be seen to be making inroads
and achieving results as part of this
but the timing is also interesting given
that arrest warrant that came down from
the international criminal court for
President Putin just last week and these
contortions that the Chinese are
striking may become more difficult to
justify especially amid these scenes of
friendship that we're likely to see
between the two men so I put some of
those questions to a spokesperson from
the foreign ministry here in Beijing
just recently and this is what he had to
say
in the last few days the international
criminal court has issued an arrest
warrant for President Putin he's also
been videoed walking around mariopol
which is a Ukrainian City that's been
illegally invaded and occupied and where
there's evidence of really horrific war
crimes having been committed by his
troops
China of course would say it's
resolutely against things like illegal
Invasion and war crimes so how can it
justify the visit of President XI going
ahead this week
that's dialogue and a negotiation is the
front of a mental way to solve the
Ukraine crisis and that's the
International Community should play a
constructive part in a peaceful
settlement of the crisis and do more
things that are conducive to promoting
peace talks
now the spokesperson also said in answer
to my question that the international
criminal court should quote not
politicize and should remain objective
so slight digs from a government that
clearly doesn't want to recognize that a
restaurant arrest warrant but it didn't
go as far as it could have done so
another example really of this careful
line that China has been treading but
remember China gets a lot of value out
of its friendship with Russia it gets a
peaceful northern border it gets a
trading partner and crucially it gets a
like-minded Ally and it's increasingly
tense standoff with the West so be in no
doubt this relationship is very
important to president XI and that
closeness is exactly what the West is
nervous about and whether China moves
closer to Russia will be a really sort
of worrying thing for the West in terms
of what might come out of this meeting